[Music]
welcome back to science clique
today the symmetries of the universe
there are many complex laws that
seemingly govern our universe
conservation of energy of momentum
general relativity the standard model of
particles
yet all this complexity emerges from a
deeper
purer concept of which all these laws
are only consequences
symmetry
[Music]
in mathematics asymmetry is a
transformation which leaves an
object unchanged a sphere for example
has a rotational symmetry
you can turn it around change its
orientation and it remains the same
an infinite rope is symmetric by
translation
we can move along the rope it remains
the same
[Music]
it turns out that the universe can also
have symmetries
a symmetry of the universe is a
transformation that does not affect
the laws of physics
to understand imagine an empty universe
in which we carry out a simple
experiment
we throw a ball once released it
continues to move in a straight line
at a constant speed
now imagine that we travel through the
universe and carry out the same
experiment
but somewhere else here too we observe
that the ball continues in a straight
line
at a constant speed it behaves in the
same way
the laws of physics have not changed
from one place to the other
this universe obeys a translational
symmetry
we can move through the universe perform
our experiment in another place
the result is always the same
this empty universe also obeys a
symmetry under rotations
we could have turned changed orientation
the result would have been the
same
finally this universe is also symmetric
through time
we could have waited and thrown the ball
a little later
the laws of physics do not change from
one instant to the next
the fact that the universe obeys
symmetries that the laws of physics
remain the same under certain
transformations
imposes restrictions on the behavior of
objects
to understand let's go back to our empty
universe
and throw the ball
[Music]
once thrown the ball acquires a forward
motion
and at the next instant it is slightly
further ahead
it has moved but if we assume that the
universe is symmetric under translation
that the laws of physics remain the same
when we change position
then the situation is equivalent to the
previous instance
the ball is moved but the laws of
physics remain the same there
and at every instant the ball therefore
evolves in the same way
if the laws of the universe are
invariant by translation
symmetry forces the ball to conserve its
motion
which explains why it traces a straight
line at a constant speed
similarly if an object rotates on itself
assuming that the laws of physics are
invariant under rotations
at the next instant the situation is
equivalent
and the symmetry will therefore force
the object to conserve its rotation
[Music]
thus to be respected each symmetry of
the universe
imposes the conservation of a quantity
conservation of momentum for
translations
momentum for rotations and energy
for symmetry through time
this principle is called nother's
theorem
each symmetry of the universe imposes
the conservation of a certain quantity
over time
no this theorem also applies to the
content of the universe
and in particular the quantum fields
that make up matter itself
a quantum field can also present
symmetries
the field of electrons for example is
made up of complex numbers
and the laws of physics that describe
electrons do not change
if we alter the phase of all these
complex numbers
to understand imagine that we measure
the altitude of an airplane on earth
to express the altitude of the airplane
we must fix a reference level
for example the sea level by fixing this
reference
we can describe the altitude by a number
but this choice of reference is
arbitrary we could have chosen another
level we would have measured
different values but the physical
situation has not changed
the same situation can be described
differently
depending on the reference level we
choose
[Music]
in the same way for the electron field
we can change the reference level
which corresponds to altering the phase
of all complex numbers
without this affecting the physical
situation which is described
this change of reference constitutes a
symmetry
and according to nother's theorem this
symmetry also imposes the conservation
of a quantity
the electric charge
conservation laws such as the
conservation of energy
or electric charge are therefore not
fundamental
in general these quantities are not
necessarily conserved
it is only when the universe presents an
underlying symmetry
that in order to be respected the
symmetry imposes the conservation of a
quantity
the principle of equal and opposite
reaction for example
which boils down to the conservation of
momentum when two objects separate
is only a consequence of symmetry under
translation
if one object goes one way the other
must go the other way
thanks to this symmetry rocket can take
off upwards
by ejecting material downwards
[Music]
however a problem arises unlike the
simplified example of an empty universe
our real universe does not appear to be
fully symmetric
at a time scale of billions of years for
example the universe expands
and it is therefore not perfectly
symmetric over time
as a result on a large scale the energy
of the universe is
not conserved light for example
gradually loses energy
its wavelength gets stretched as the
universe expands
the universe is not perfectly symmetric
under translations either
it contains stars and planets and is
therefore not the same
everywhere at this scale thus if we
throw an object
in general its momentum is not conserved
on earth for example an apple falls
downwards
it accelerates its movement changes over
time because the situation
is not symmetric
[Music]
at first glance our universe does not
seem to respect symmetries
even worse the laws of physics appear to
be different
depending on the frame from which we
observe
if we drop a ball inside a centrifuge
from the outside the ball seems to
conserve its movement
but from the inside the movement of the
ball is not conserved
it accelerates towards the surface
how can we explain that the ball behaves
differently
the laws of physics are absolute if we
want a good description of our universe
we would like all objects whatever our
point of view
to always obey the same laws
when changing point of view the laws of
the universe should not change
they must remain the same for everyone
yet the behavior of the bull
is not the same
[Music]
to solve this problem to restore the
invariance of the laws of physics
for the ball to be described by the same
laws from both points of view
it would be necessary to add a new
element to our description
to understand let's go back to the
previous analogy
we measure the altitude of an airplane
the plane is moving straight ahead
and if we take the sea level as a
reference we measure a constant altitude
it draws a straight line
[Music]
that said let's imagine that we took the
surface of the earth
as a reference this time because of the
mountains we measure an altitude that
varies
over time as if the plane was moving in
zigzags
taking the surface as a reference the
behavior of the airplane now seems
different
but the situation is not changed the
plane is moving straight ahead
how can we explain that while it faces
straight ahead its altitude
varies over time to solve this paradox
it is necessary to introduce some kind
of force field that would push the
airplane up or down
depending on the reference level that
we've chosen thus
explaining its behavior when going from
one reference level to another
from sea level to land level it is
necessary to add this force field to
properly account for the behavior of the
aircraft
[Music]
going back to the example of the ball in
the centrifuge
the situation is exactly the same moving
from one point of view to the other
from outside to inside the centrifuge
the bull seems to obey different laws
and it is necessary to add some kind of
force field to our description
this is what we call inertial forces and
in particular the centrifugal and
coriolis forces
by adding these inertial forces we
reinstate the laws of physics
as absolute the behavior of the ball can
now be understood very well
in any frame of reference as long as we
add this force field which depends on
which point of view we choose
introducing this kind of force field is
also what gives rise to the concept of
space-time curvature
and to the theory of general relativity
general relativity is a very powerful
theory precisely because it restores the
absoluteness
of the laws of physics by adding a new
underlying structure
the curvature of space-time general
relativity makes it possible to describe
the universe from any point of view
using the same equations
[Music]
surprisingly enough this reasoning
adding a field to restore the invariance
of the laws of physics
is also the basis for all fundamental
interactions
in particle physics we have seen that
the quantum field of electrons has a
symmetry
the laws which describe it are invariant
when we shift the phase of all
complex numbers globally
but if we alter the phase differently in
different parts of the field
locally which amounts to choosing a
reference level in zigzags like the
surface of the earth
the laws which describe electrons seem
to have changed
in other words this change of reference
is not
a symmetry if we want to re-establish
the laws of physics as absolute
for this to be a symmetry whatever
reference level we choose
we need to change our description we
must introduce
another underlying structure a kind of
force field
with which the electron field interacts
to account
for this change in behavior
[Music]
this other structure is called the
electromagnetic field
it contains particles that interact with
electrons
photons
[Music]
in a way if two objects repel each other
due to their electric
charge if we do not fall through our
chair when we sit
and if light exists in the universe it
is thanks to this local symmetry
being able to choose any reference level
for complex numbers
which requires the existence of a new
field and new particles
the photons with which the electrons
interact
[Music]
to conclude studying the symmetries of
the universe allows us to understand in
a deep way
the origin of the laws which govern it
it is because the universe has
symmetries
that the objects it contains in order to
respect these symmetries
obey physical laws be it conservation of
energy
or momentum objects obey these laws only
to respect underlying symmetries
intrinsic to the universe
by considering that the laws of physics
must be absolute
that changing our point of view or level
of reference must constitute a symmetry
that does not affect the physical
reality we call this a gauge symmetry
we deduce the presence of new structures
in the universe
like the curvature of space-time or the
electromagnetic field
[Music]
experimentally symmetries also allow us
to unveil the hidden mysteries
of matter by measuring certain
properties of particles
and by studying the geometric diagrams
that we obtain
symmetries have allowed scientists to
understand for instance
that protons neutrons and other baryons
are formed of three smaller objects
which obey a fundamental symmetry based
on the number three
quarks there are also discrete
symmetries
for example inverting the charge
direction through space as well as
direction through time
of all particles constitutes a symmetry
an anti-particle can in this way be
interpreted as an ordinary
particle that moves backwards through
time
finally some speculative modern theories
postulate that the universe could have
an even deeper symmetry
a symmetry between particles of matter
and particles of interaction
as if both obeyed the same laws
this is what we call supersymmetry
[Music]
[Music]
you